would have known driving a warship in
waters of crimea would catch russia's
eye
russian jets tracking the destroyer
moscow alleges one of its ships and
planes
even fired warning shots nonsense says
britain this route
the defense secretary also dismissed
claims hms defender entered russian
territorial waters
saying they belong to ukraine i mean
these are the things that come and go
with russia disinformation
misinformation is something that we have
seen regularly
we're not surprised by it we plan for it
and we take all steps to make sure that
we are not
escalatory or indeed provocative uh
however we will not shy away from
upholding international law
and our rights on the sea the view from
the kremlin
is very different
our country's defense ministry already
gave a professional valuation of the
dangerous
actions of britain's destroyer i would
like to add that we treat it as a
blatant british provocation that is
contrary with international law and
russian legislation
the war of words was triggered after
britain's destroyer left ukraine where
it had been on a visit
it carried out what the uk described as
a routine transit
from the port of odessa towards georgia
across the black sea
the warships coordinates show how close
it sailed past crimea
which was annexed in 2014 by russia
in a move that's not internationally
recognized
russia says it fired warning shots and
one of its planes dropped bombs in the
ship's path to alter its passage
but the uk said the russians had instead
been conducting
a pre-planned gunnery exercise some
three miles away
moscow claims the 12 nautical miles off
crimea's coast as its own
territorial waters but they're viewed by
the uk
as ukrainian testing boundaries is
nothing new
here a russian carrier passed through
the english channel four years ago
this close encounter more recent
but britain was clearly ready to test
its rite of passage
after this stop in ukraine and ready to
defend itself
not least in the battle of narratives
the the mod response has been really
fast
and so often these are held up as they
go through the sector state and into
number 10 and by the time the sequencing
is all aligned
it's too late today the mod were very
quick to put out a de-escalatory
statement and said this is what's
happened this is what didn't happen i
thought that was
impressive and a good sign of things to
come but russia is a master of
information
cameras ready to capture the british
defense satashi being summoned
no actual clashes at sea but real
tensions on the land
debra haynes sky news